yeah I'm sorry to this video playing
five minute game here against yacht bird
again Grandmaster little brawn and turn
it some the start of the new blood
session here early in the morning and
it's not moving not much I can do at the
moment okay now his size moving what am
I going to play maybe you just don't go
for kings in the end type of setup
alright so it's not playing d for
transposing to to a pure Kings inion but
on this is this should be quite quite
playable for black okay p son plane
efore transposing into a buddha Vinick
type of setup with fon c4 yeah more than
one player available maybe you prepare
behind this is one possible idea and the
structure his night is some slightly
miss plays that usually be no sony too
but it's not them it's not terrible
anything but ok h3 is also normal to
cover the g four square hmm 927 i also
had the idea to play Bishop g4 earlier
to just get rid of the bishop sometimes
this Bishop is really a very useless
piece doesn't have fun a great square of
course in this structure I can always
put it on b7
but it's not them entirely clear what it
is doing there okay playing with befall
and possibly even a form yeah it's not
be six an idea now you can probably
still 84 takes on C 4 than a 5 how to
continue mp4 p a bit term be traveling
maybe maybe still too smooth on a for
exchanging twice and then again maybe
going for 85 don't think you can take on
c6 a form meow I wanted to take with
okay it's just just protecting see form
not a not a bad choice of course okay I
come on let's let's try this but should
be six attacking c4 you know it looks
like a bad structure will have a5 p.m.
this was my intention now i get rid of
this pawn when you place a three or he
plays be five and a half 97 to c5 as a
possible continuation is also a bit tied
to this c4 weakness well maybe just 83
now for what this looks like the most
devon yeah conservative but the most
solid move okay this was my idea anyway
intending to take on b5 at some moment
yeah and now I'm on known I Munsey form
okay but again he can play 95 now the
question is it der is it so I'm so
terrible now that's nothing really
threatening can drop this back and light
efore to c5 this was my original idea
that's probably it was probably okay
maybe I'm at some point I need to take
this night it's um it's really a great
piece down
yeah I know it improves the spawn
structure but it's not clear that this
zone is helping him the night on c5
always attacks the b3 porn and you know
now suspected that this was maybe even
even better route b6 um I can I cannot
play Queen a phone again I need to go
back open it sound nothing nothing
terrible I hope okay then it's hard to
believe that this should be so I'm so
great for white want to get out of this
check see an Knight f6 check and stuff
if i move the the bishop later
you have the problem is some that I'm
severely down on time and and I'm happy
he manages this year this doesn't look
good line morning okay now I couldn't be
five he can go this is some really bad I
mean can take a queen bee five hunter
and that's it yeah this wasn't really
necessary but it is so is good as well
yeah okay oops of course not just a just
run button yeah yeah yeahs me somehow
plate me here I don't think that this
shouldn't be too overwhelming but so I
mean that it's a pretty healthy
structure on the queenside it's a bit
quicker on the be found but yeah maybe
the Sun this wasn't so great horse rupee
three was was strong I mean he really
understood the position here it takes
speed isn't so good this is better hmm
yeah this is strong of course I I unless
tomato this rainy this Bishop takes d5
leads to a very one-sided position is
just got the beef I'll I hear the
computer points out an interesting move
Bishop to age 16 yeah this is strong
activating the bishop but I have a hard
time believing that this really should
be on something substantial for white
with this structure now but maybe the B
file is so important that it doesn't
really matter it's also a constant
problem that I cannot really look at
this the normal move would be eight
simply I cannot cannot do this giving up
the Queen and this is also of course
nonsensical well maybe why this pattern
i don't know i probably am over
estimated that the position here I
didn't think I was better or something
but I thought that it would be pretty
okay maybe this Bishop age six son
movers what I should have played
activating this piece yeah an
interesting game nevertheless thanks for
watching